-It was revealed that
famous Hollywood producer
Harvey Weinstein has been
sexually harassing women
and then paying them
to keep quiet about it.
And as stunning
as the allegations are,
equally stunning was the apology
that Weinstein issued
after the article was published.
Here to comment
are three of our writers,
Amber, Ally, and Jenny,
everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, thank you for having us.
Seth, how did you feel
when you heard the allegations?
-I was disgusted and shocked.
How did you feel?
-Well, I was disgusted
and not shocked.
-I was disgusted and shocked
that it took this long
to become a story.
-I was disgusted and shocked
that people were shocked.
[ Laughter ]
Seth, we want to start
by applauding the women
who went on the record
to detail Harvey Weinstein's
terrible behavior.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So far we know Weinstein
reached cash settlements
with eight women.
And where there are eight,
there are always more.
-And whatever details you hear,
just know that means there are
worse details we haven't heard.
-And the ones we have heard
are terrible.
One woman said Harvey Weinstein
cornered her in a nightclub,
and then,
when she wouldn't kiss him,
masturbated into a potted plant.
[ Audience groans ]
-And then the plant
got a three-picture deal.
[ Laughter ]
-Also in his apology,
he blamed disrespect of women on
growing up in the '60s and '70s,
which would be a good excuse
if he came to the present
via time machine.
-Yeah, did he not notice
things have been changing
over the past 50 years?
-Does he lose his [bleep]
every time he sees a microwave?
"That man just made popcorn
without a flame!"
[ Laughter ]
-To make matters worse,
he said he was going to
go after the NRA and Trump,
as if our shared politics
makes his sexual assault okay.
-Hey, I saw a guy masturbate
into a plant.
-Oh, no!
-But it was okay
because he was wearing
a Planned Parenthood button.
-Cool!
-Oh, he's a feminist! Cool.
-When he got busted,
Weinstein said,
"To make up for it,
I'm starting a scholarship
for women directors."
That's just him
being around more women.
That's not the solution,
that's the problem.
[ Laughter ]
That's like Jared from Subway
saying, "I know I messed up,
but don't worry,
I'm starting a tee ball league."
[ Laughter ]
-You know who else is sexually
harassing women every day?
Unpowerful men like bus drivers.
-And hot dog vendors.
And improv coaches.
-And improv coaches.
[ Light laughter ]
-Every woman
in the American workforce
has been harassed at some point,
-Whether
it's physical harassment
or a passing
inappropriate comment,
this is something
women deal with every day.
-Which is why, while we weren't
shocked by Weinstein's actions,
the women on our staff
had some pretty strong reactions
to his apology.
Take a look.
-"I came of age
in the '60s and '70s
when all the rules about
behavior in workplaces
were different"?
[ Spitting ]
-"I so respect all women"?
[ Sigh ]
-"I've decided I'm going to give
the NRA my full attention."
[ Breaking glass ]
[ Yelling ]
-He compared himself to Jay-Z?
[ Spitting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Pop! ]
[ Shattering ]
-He said
that was the culture then.
[ Spitting ]
-He said
that was the culture then.
[ Spitting ]
-Don't drink that.
He said
it was the culture back then.
[ Spitting ]
[ Light laughter ]
-Sorry.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Obviously that was awful,
but harassment's clearly
a huge problem in our society.
Do you guys have any thoughts
on how to change that?
-Yeah,
sexual harassment training.
-Yeah, believing women when they
come forward with complaints.
-Also, men could just
stop being such [bleep] creeps.
-Oh!
-That! Do that!
That is a great idea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You should write down.
Someone should write that down.
And you know, the worst part is
nothing's going to happen
to Harvey Weinstein.
As shocking
as these allegations are,
the real shocking thing
would be if there were any
repercussions for his actions.
-Oh, well, actually, guys,
it was just announced yesterday
by the board of
the Weinstein Company
that he has been fired.
[ Spitting ]
[ Laughter ]
-That's amazing.
-I am shocked. Fully shocked.
-Shocking in the best way.
-Amber, Ally, and Jenny,
everyone!
We'll be right back with more
with Senator Cory Booker!